you know
[Music]
um I as many of you are I'm watching
very closely vaccination numbers coveted
case numbers deaths Etc we're trying to
figure out are we headed towards hell
again in the fall what is happening with
the Delta variant what about the next
variant what's happening in Europe which
seems to sort of be a leading indicator
for what we might expect here in the
United States and so on and so forth and
then you just look at what's happening
around the country and you realize hey
guys uh they're fighting against us they
they're so the anti-vaxx right wing has
become a monster essentially of its own
making so big that they may prevent the
country from being as great as they
claim to want it to be they talk about
make America great again they talk about
America first they talk about all this
stuff and then they don't want to get
vaccinated which is what will help the
economy and it will help prevent death
and it will help prevent hospitalization
and I want to look at some video with
you today
of Arkansas Republican governor governor
ASA Hutchinson now I don't want to go
overboard in my praise of Republicans
but I want to mention that in the last
week or so many prominent Republican
leaders have started being much more
positive about coveted vaccines I think
it's basically motivated by economic
concerns and the realization that it's
increasingly becoming a republican virus
because Republicans want vaccinations at
such a lower rate than Democrats
overwhelmingly you are seeing red
counties Republican Counties have a
higher per capita case rate okay so
Governor ASA Hutchinson does an event uh
with State vaccine official Dr Jennifer
delaha and he says very basic simple
things like the vaccine doesn't cause
infertility which is one conspiracy
that's been floating around
and he gets booed listen to this does
this impact fertility well the answer is
no and that's been the data but they
what kind of person Boos the news that
hey great news the vaccine doesn't
impact fertility as far as we know right
now based on all the evidence we've seen
they've created a monster they can't
control Hutchinson then defers to the
state's vaccine Authority and it just
gets very ugly
Dr Delhi do you want to answer that so
at this point it's delaya not dillah I
apologize at any time there is no
ever
can you imagine
[Applause]
the same energy from from which burnings
right I mean it's that they will not
hear any alternative view to this is a
witch these are lies about vaccines
anymore
go ahead doctor so there is no medical
evidence at this time that the Copic
vaccines impact fertility there is a
great deal of evidence that the covet
illness itself
causes problems with pregnancy and Fetal
demise so so understand that the
evidence isn't that the vaccine causes
fertility issues the evidence is covid
can cause issues with pregnancy how do
you talk rationally with these people I
mean how reach across the aisle who who
are you reaching out to and this is
something that we're getting more and
more information about I think it it's
worth repeating women's periods and the
immune system are connected uh as a
woman is about to ovulate her immune
system ramps itself up to prevent any
infectious agent from interfering with
the start of a pregnancy with the
fertilization and implantation of the
egg
once that egg is fertilized and then
implants the immune system dampens to
accept the pregnancy the uterus has
immune cells those can be affected by
hormonal changes the immune system and
cortisol which is the stress hormone
those are related and periods respond to
cortisol levels so the long and short of
it is there are anecdotal reports of a
late period in some women after the
second dose of the vaccine it's possible
that the covid vaccines could impact one
or maybe two periods following the
second dose in terms of a delay for
example because the immune system of the
woman is hard at work developing
immunity or because of cortisol levels
as Dr daleja is stating there is no
evidence of an impact on fertility
there's no evidence of any long-term
effects
and there is evidence that a bigger risk
to pregnancy than being vaccinated is
getting covered for a pregnant woman but
the crowd doesn't want to hear it so
again for everybody saying we've got to
just relate to these people we've got to
reach across the aisle get them
vaccinated I'm with you
but how do you do that where they
literally start chanting they become I
hate to use a term that is uh uh a
portmanteau created by former producer
Lewis they become feverant yeah I know
it's not a word but you can look that
one up on Urban Dictionary how do you
calm them down they're experiencing this
outrageous state of like a hyper arousal
where they just can't stop screaming
when a doctor is simply saying there's
no evidence of that I don't know how you
connect with those people but it is very
scary stuff in terms of what it means
for the United States reaching herd
immunity if that's even still something
we think we might be able to do
one of our sponsors is privacy.com
they're giving you five dollars when you
sign up for their completely free
service at privacy.com Pacman I've been
using privacy for a little over a year
now you've heard me talk about it before
it's a lifesaver and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something online or on
the phone instead of actually using your
real credit card number the privacy app
and the browser plugin let you give each
company a randomized virtual credit card
number that you create out of thin air
it'll even auto fill the card number
with one click and the payment is taken
out of your checking account without the
merchant ever knowing your real
information so this allows you to keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create up to 12 of these virtual credit
cards a month you can set spending
limits you can freeze them you can
delete them anytime you want so when you
do this it means you're not going to to
be charged when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number right after using it which for
instance I love using free trials
because I know I won't be charged when
the trial is over if I use a virtual
credit card number you're keeping your
identity private by not telling
companies who you are you're keeping
your bank or credit card info protected
against data breaches and identity theft
and it's free and like I said you'll get
five dollars to spend when you sign up
at privacy.com Pacman